bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on pas parler
d'argent de monétisation sur youtube
savoir comment gagner de l'argent c'est
une vidéo hors série un petit peu
particulière par rapport à ce que je
peux faire habituellement cet été
j'avais déjà fait pas mal de vidéos
pourraient d'un pelé youtuber a
progressé sur youtube
aujourd'hui on va parler d'argent
comment gagner de l'argent avec les
marques et vous allez voir c'est
extrêmement facile
[Musique]
comment gagner de l'argent sur youtube
quand on crée une chaîne youtube on se
pose la question c'est pas forcément
comment comment gagner de l'argent et en
réalité c'est assez simple alors
effectivement il vous faut une audience
il vous faut une stratégie mais une fois
que vous avez dit tout ça en place que
vous avez une audience il existe en gros
cinq moyens de green arrow sur youtube
vous avez d'ailleurs aller voir cette
vidéo j'en ai déjà parlé dedans alors
pour résumer vous pouvez gagner d'argent
avec une régie pub google adsense qu'on
connaît le plus mais c'est pas forcément
ce qui marche le mieux
ensuite il peut gagner de l'argent avec
de la filiation amazon et les
plateformes comme ça dès lors vous
vendent un produit vous est commissionné
vous pouvez divergent avec votre
communauté directement avec des sites
comme tipi les gens vous donnent de
l'argent et en face à y avoir des
contreparties
vous pouvez ensuite vendre directement
vos produits comme des ebooks ou des
choses comme ça vous vous transmettez un
savoir et il existe une dernière
solution qui marche super bien et que je
vous recommande un ton appareil
justement tout de suite c'est travailler
avec des marques avec des annonceurs en
direct il ya des plateformes qui existe
et justement je vous en parlais d'une
particulière aujourd'hui j'ai testé que
je trouve plutôt pas mal
s'appelle céline hop vous mettre le lien
dans la description en dessous c'est
plutôt bien foutu le principe c'est vous
vous inscrivez vous inscrivez votre
chaîne youtube
c'est simple c'est facile il n'y a rien
de compliqué sans engagement c'est
gratuit
c'est par network vous est présentée sur
la plateforme dès lors qu'il ya un
annonceur qui veut communiquer
directement sur votre chaîne il ya une
proposition vous voyez ça vous intéresse
oui ou non par rapport à la valeur mans
une nouvelle chaîne vous pouvez refuser
vous n'êtes pas du tout obligé
d'accepter par rapport à votre nombre
d'abonnés votre chaîne a une certaine
valeur financière
et justement c'est ça que vous allez
monétiser et c'est plutôt intéressant
pour être plus concret ce qu'on va faire
je vous montrer comment ça marche vous
montrer comment moi je me suis inscris
comment ça se passe point par point et
ensuite vous allez voir comment sont les
villes et comment on peut vous trouver
et franchement c'est sain c'est pas une
recette miracle
c'est pas parce que vous allez vous
inscrire dessus que vous allez avoir
directement des annonceurs mais si vous
avez une chaîne qui est pertinente dans
une niche particulière et vous avez bien
furent désabonnez vous avez quelque
chose à valoriser en face il ya un
annonceur qui cherche quelqu'un comme
vous il va vous trouver et en face ça
peut vous
et vous à gagner d'argent sur you tube
single ça ressemble à ça c'est
effectivement une plateforme globale sur
laquelle on va pouvoir s'inscrire pour
gagner de l'argent pour monétiser ses
vidéos d'où ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est les influenceurs vidéo sur youtube
marketing alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
on va d'abord créer un compte gratuit et
sans engagement et vous allez voir c'est
super simple alors on s'inscrit monsieur
bon ben moi je suis un particulier
prénom monsieur non greu nom
d'utilisateur monsieur re un mot de
passe vous confirmer les mots de passe
vous rentrez ici toutes vos données de
contacts vous saisissez votre email et
on balance
alors maintenant est ce que vous arrivez
dans cette partie vous avez le mode de
paiement l'enregistrement du mode de
paiement
le mode de paiement des notes de crédit
c'est le moyen pour vous faire payer
vous en tant que publie chantant que
youtube heures directement alors moi ce
que je vous conseille c'est de rentrer
si votre compte paypal vous rentrez
votre adresse pour faire payer si vous
n'avez pas de compte paypal vous pouvez
faire également bien sûr par virement
vous rentrez votre nom le nom de votre
banque votre iban
ici votre pays c'est et vous recevrez
tous vos paiements par virement
le mode de paiement pour les factures
concerne uniquement les annonceurs ce
qui bien sûr n'est pas votre cas donc ça
ne vous sert strictement rien qu'on
clients alors maintenant ce qui vous
intéresse et de définir le produit là
typiquement vous avez le choix entre
plusieurs cases à cocher participation
tant qu'annonceur seeding de contenus
bloc marketing seeding social est ce fps
ça ne vous intéresse pas participation
tant que publishers' monétisation de
blogs ou de produits réseaux sociaux
youtube ça c'est vous vous êtes
publishers' vous avez une pas un compte
youtube que vous souhaitez monétiser
vous cochez cette case
ça c'est réservé aux annonceurs ça ne
vous intéresse pas la programmation de
campagne d'affiliation sais pas pour
vous je ne sais pas
non vous cochez bien la case
participation en tant que publie cher
c'est pour vous les emails vous pouvez
le voir refaire le choix de les recevoir
ou pas moi je vous conseille quand même
de cliquer pour les recevoir
tout simplement pour connaître les
nouveautés produits de nouveautés de la
plate forme ça peut être vraiment
intéressant pour vous et on suit bien
évidemment il faut avoir lu et accepté
les conditions générales de vente et la
protection des données bien évidemment
et ensuite on clique sur continuez vous
à lens autissier intergraphic relatif
entre vos modes de paiement vos données
qui vous êtes ou est-ce que vous êtes
votre email et ensuite vous validez
votre compte directement ici alors ce
que je vous conseille moi c'est vous
allez dans vos emails vous cliquez et
hop ça vous active directement votre
compte et vous vous en mettez pas
activation réussi ça roule ma poule
ensuite vous vous identifiez vous
arrivez directement sur la plateforme
vous ce qui vous intéresse maintenant
c'est paramétrer directement votre
youtube marketing et de créer une offre
vous allez sur l'onglet d'abord
publishers' vous allez créer une
nouvelle offre alors l'offre
on va chercher ça va être de
influenceurs vidéo directement ici url
de votre offre
ça va être directement l'url de votre
chaîne youtube alors vous avez sur votre
janeiro vous avez directement l'url de
votre chef vous retournez sur céline up
vous taper l'url de votre chaîne
directement ici et vous créez une offre
ou choisissez la langue alors vous
choisissez mais sur la catégorie qui
correspond directement à ma chaise
ensuite vous taper une petite
description qu'elle t'aime souhaitez
vous exclure et bien strictement aucun
sexe âge vous n'êtes pas obligé de le
mettre
vous continuez ensuite dans votre
inscription une fois vous avez inscrit
votre chaîne veille vous avez le nom de
votre chaîne l'url le nombre d'abonnés
le nombre de vidéos le nombre de vues
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas encore été mis à
jour
il ya des annonceurs pour pouvoir vous
trouver directement par votre catégorie
c'est super facile
ensuite alors ça va vous trouver il va
vous envoyer une proposition vous la
regardez vous avez une offre de vidéo
vous pouvez accepter la refusez vous
êtes m à tout moment
ensuite lorsque vous avez une
réservation s'élevant de petit brief de
l'annonceur qui veut dire d'un côté
voilà je voudrais bien qu'on parle de ça
dans la vidéo qu'on laborde sous talent
d'essayer ça et bien évidemment le prix
auquel annonceurs va vous vous vous
payez pour la publication votre vidéo
alors la vidéo début vous l'a publié pas
directement
il doit être validé par le client vous
la mettez en ont répertorié voulu
envoyer le lien de la vidéo mais
regardez ça lui va on publier
directement s'il va pas il ya des
modifications à faire pour un peu le
principe c'est extrêmement simple que
vous lisez la plateforme est gratuite
vous vous inscrivez et en quelques clics
vous pouvez vous mettre à disposition
des annonceurs qui peuvent faire appel à
vos services pour des besoins de
communication
n'oubliez pas lorsque vous faites des
vidéos sponsors vous devez toujours être
loyal toujours dire la vérité est ce que
c'est bien oui non pourquoi comment
parce que sinon après si votre
communauté sans rencontre elle ne vous
croira plus voilà un petit peu ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui sur cette plate
forme c line up et j'espère que ça vous
aura intéressé alors il ya d'autres
plateformes qui glissa là je trouve
intéressante se trouve vraiment
pertinents il ya plusieurs solutions si
vous avez un blog vous pouvez aussi
aller sur paris et pas mal de choses à
faire là dessus vous invite à aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil directement
il ya plein d'autres moyenne
baptisé aller voir la vidéo dont je vais
parler un petit plus tôt et vous verrez
qu'il existe plein plein plein pas une
bonne solution pour monétiser pour édith
l'argent sur youtube pour pouvoir enfin
espérer en vivre
merci beaucoup inscrivez-vous à ma
chaîne parce qu'on vante un contenu
alors pour la monétisation pour youtube
benoît un petit peu mais c'est vraiment
confidentiel mais surtout parlé de take
2 high tech de plein de nouveaux
produits les tendances
abonnez vous inscrivez vous marquez m'a
tout ce que vous voulez en commentaire
et on en parle ensemble
[Musique]